[Aplausos]
el tema de mi presentación se llama la
mejor ciudad del mundo
desde hace algunos años hemos visto
muchísimas listas circulando por el
internet que hablan sobre la mejor
ciudad del mundo todas las listas dicen
que es una ciudad diferente no ninguna
coincide incluso también hay listas de
las mejores ciudades de méxico entre
ellas podemos encontrar desde las que a
mí me parecen no tan buenas hasta otras
que no conozco
y la paz en una de las últimas listas
está en los primeros diez lugares
pero bueno cuál es la mejor ciudad del
mundo es algo muy difícil es una
pregunta muy difícil de contestar porque
lo que es mejor para mí no
necesariamente es lo mejor para alguien
más
pero para mí la mejor ciudad del mundo
es la ciudad en la que vivo la paz
aunque yo no nací aquí desde que llegué
me enamoré de los paisajes las playas
los atardeceres y de la vida submarina
de la paz
y precisamente fue el mar lo que me
trajo aquí
estudia biología marina hice mis
prácticas profesionales en un
laboratorio de acuacultura de peces en
un centro de investigación un verano me
quedé encargada de todo el laboratorio y
una noche llegó un huracán
yo estaba súper nerviosa porque si llega
a fallar algo en el laboratorio pues se
moría el trabajo de muchos científicos
en la mañana siguiente fui a revisar los
tanques y me encontré con que uno de los
tanques tenía el agua super turbia y los
peces que estaban ahí se estaban
comportando de una manera muy agresiva
incluso uno había saltado fuera del
tanque se había suicidado
pues pude solucionar el problema pero
algo quedó muy en mi mente ahí fue donde
entendí que el medio que rodea los seres
vivos determina en gran medida su
comportamiento y estado de ánimo
por las mismas fechas había un grupo de
personas manifestándose en contra de la
construcción de un complejo turístico en
el mogote que está justo en frente de la
ciudad de la paz
pues yo venía llegando de hermosillo
entonces me interesaba el tema pero no
me involucre mucho porque pensaba que
era normal que cuando las ciudades
crecían este tipo de proyectos sucedían
además pues no tenía idea de que podía
hacer yo para detenerlo no tenía ningún
poder ni siquiera pensaba que tuviera la
capacidad de hacer algo al respecto
hasta que un día esos atardeceres que yo
veía todos los días dejaron de meterse
atrás de las montañas para esconderse
atrás de unos edificios me sentí muy muy
mal porque nunca pensé que algo
aparentemente tan lejano me pudiera
afectar tanto
los atardeceres de la paz no volvieron a
ser los mismos desde entonces este tipo
de complejos turísticos estaban
queriendo se construir en todo el estado
incluso llegaron a amenazar balandra que
es una playa que es icono de la paz y es
la playa pública por excelencia
muchas personas aprendieron a nadar aquí
un grupo de un pequeño grupo de personas
se juntaron para con un objetivo muy
particular proteger balanda en esta
ocasión no dude en sumarme a estos
esfuerzos
en muy poco tiempo gracias a muchísimos
voluntarios ya las nuevas redes sociales
que nos empezaban a llegar aquí a la paz
este pequeño grupo creció hasta ser más
de 18 mil personas de todos tipos desde
amas de casas estudiantes científicos
abogados deportistas artistas de todo y
después de siete años de esfuerzos
porque no fue fácil ni rápido
logramos que balandra fuera decretada un
área natural protegida todos estábamos
convencidos ahora sí de que balandra era
nuestra este evento que sucedió aquí en
la ciudad de la paz nos cambio a todos
los que vivimos aquí porque a partir de
ese entonces nos empezamos a dar cuenta
de que realmente sí teníamos poder a
comparación de los pesos si teníamos
poder de dirigir las cosas no deben de
decidir que queríamos para nuestro
futuro pero qué es lo que nos distingue
de los peces y otros animales que
nosotros tenemos imaginación
y esa mi imaginación la usamos para
imaginar nuestro futuro
para soñar nuestro futuro y cuando somos
capaces de distinguir a las personas que
comparten estos sueños con nosotros o
somos lo suficientemente hábiles para
compartirlo con los demás y convencerlos
de que realmente este sueño
vale la pena llevarlo a cabo nos podemos
organizar y hacerlo realidad
y precisamente esa es una de las cosas
por las cuales la ciudad de la paz es mi
ciudad favorita y por la cual yo creo
que la paz puede ser la mejor ciudad del
mundo porque somos muchísimos los que
estamos trabajando para mejorar nuestro
entorno no nada más soñamos sino que lo
llevamos a cabo
y precisamente en pláticas con amigos
soñadores fue que nació urban ería
en estas pláticas discutíamos que la paz
podía ser la mejor ciudad del mundo con
la acción directa de sus habitantes pero
por dónde empezar si hay tantas cosas
que se tienen que mejorar decidimos
elegir el espacio público porque es aquí
donde todos coincidimos nosotros
sabíamos que con muy poquito esfuerzo
con estructuras simples de bajo costo
con sombras naturales de árboles nativos
nativos y obras de arte podríamos
mejorar pequeños espacios públicos en la
ciudad todo esto si la lleven si la
gente nos ayudaba no si teníamos más
mano de obra y más ideas
entonces decidimos unir esfuerzos
recursos y propósitos para intervenir un
pedacito de un arroyo
hicimos una invitación por las redes
sociales y pensamos que iba a llegar muy
poca gente solamente nuestros amigos nos
resulta que llegaron más de 100 personas
y muchos de ellos ni los conocíamos
participaron estudiantes maestros
personas que trabajan en asociaciones
civiles gente que trabaja en el gobierno
niños mujeres hombres de todo un poco y
en un solo día logramos reforestar un
pedazo de arroyo sacamos varios
toneladas de escombro y de basura
y desde ese momento los vecinos se han
encargado de sembrar más árboles en esa
zona y de cuidarlos desde el 2012 en
urban ería hemos realizado más de 25
intervenciones con la ayuda de más de
1000 personas esto es muchísimo no
porque todos lo hemos hecho con muy poco
presupuesto muchas veces nos dicen que
no se pueden hacer las cosas porque no
hay presupuesto pero realmente sí se
puede
estas estas intervenciones aunque están
muy lejos de ser perfectas
lo que sí aportan a la comunidad es que
las personas que participan terminan
mejorando sus habilidades o adquiriendo
habilidades nuevas
lo que hacen genera una sensación de
satisfacción y de orgullo
y fortalecen el tejido social
pues nosotros sabemos que lo que nos
rodea es lo que nos define como sociedad
y es lo que indica hacia dónde queremos
llegar la paz está en medio está rodeada
de bellezas naturales estamos en medio
de un paraíso y nuestras áreas naturales
protegidas también son nuestros espacios
públicos y eso nos tiene que quedar muy
claro a todos estos áreas naturales
protegidas pueden llegar a ser uno
pueden llegar a ser una inspiración para
construir parques dentro de nuestra
ciudad e incluso pueden llegar a ser
parte de estas no
yo sigo trabajando en lo que me trajo
aquí el mar
comparto
trato de compartir con la gente de la
paz las bellezas submarinas y la
importancia de nuestros vecinos marinos
que los tenemos ahí y que son parte
importante de nuestra identidad una sola
persona no puede cambiar las cosas no
puedes salvar el mundo pero muchas
personas sí y este nosotros que
aprendemos a soñar con que con un mismo
objetivo para que todos podamos aportar
diferentes soluciones y diferentes
opciones para participar y con esto
provocar que más gente se anime a
aportarle algo a su ciudad los peces no
pueden cambiar su estanque no pueden
determinar su medio pero nosotros si los
invito a inspirarse de todas las
bellezas que nos rodean para hacer que
la paz sea la mejor ciudad del mundo si
se puede
[Aplausos]